Raleigh Tucson Phoenix Monterey
Vancouver Napa Oklahoma City Palm Beach
Inglewood Huntington New Brunswick Tim
dilloncomedy.com we'll see you out there
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show Army Hammer now coming back
uh has an apology I don't I never
understood what the big deal was with
Army Hammer and why he was in so much
trouble I know that there was this
sticky situation and people have used
the word rape and stuff but from my
understanding he was just fantasizing
about eating people which is legal
you're allowed to fantasize about being
accountable it may not be a fetish that
you know is widely accepted and I'm not
projecting by the way don't be like well
this is you're projecting and you're
clearing I I don't want to eat people
I'm saying that you're allowed to a guy
like Army Hammer
who like if that's what gets him off
eating
imagining eating okay
a consenting adult now obviously people
would go can you consent to be being
eaten
um yeah
probably but also if this was in the
realm of fantasy like if he never did it
if he never cut somebody up if he never
cooked human flesh if this was just
something that got him off I don't
understand why we are quote unquote kink
shaming someone who's into this this is
what they're into we don't know why he's
into it although now he's he's saying a
youth pastor molested him and that's why
he's into it he said he's been in a BDSM
since 13. his words not mine and to me I
don't understand uh if it's in the realm
of fantasy why because you got to
remember Armie Hammer is so attractive
having sex with an attractive person
stop being interesting to him probably
about I don't know 17 years old
most people it's a porn everything's
about [__] someone hot
that's the whole game of attraction that
gets you dick hard it gets your [__]
wet if somebody's hot quite simply big
tits big dick whatever it is that gets
someone hot Army hammers done that
maybe thousands of times he's bored with
that it doesn't get him going anymore
because he's had those experience the
experiences that you dream of in your
life when you're sitting there in your
couch and you're waiting for a a
Postmates or a Uber Eats driver to knock
on the door and hand you Thai food that
you slurp down and you get sticky and
you watch you know
the experiences in the back of your mind
that keep you going that animate you
he's done those all of them like a lot
he's bored anything you think about
[__] on a beach guarantee Army
Hammer's done it [__] on a private
art he's done it [__] here oh look
we're coming in the Eiffel Tower is in a
backdrop three women how about that
skipping threesomes right to orgies I'm
Army [__] Hammer he's [__] every
he's [__] everybody from every race
Brazilian women uh whatever Norwegian
women every race he's [__] the only
thing that will get him going now is the
idea that he can eat one of them that's
it that's the only thing that gets him
off now is the fantasy that one day he
would eat a woman to possess them fully
and completely as they uh would then
live in his belly and I'm not saying
that that's the easiest thing to bring
hump at a dinner party I don't envy Army
Hammer I think it's a it's not an easy
fetish but let's read some of these uh
DMS he sent to people that are
supposedly that bad and then we'll look
at his apology
um because I think he went down and he
sold time shares and he's kind of like
you know he's he's been punished
I believe they also looked into the Rave
thing they go we don't know how if that
case is really and again I believe all
you know I believe all people who pay me
so I I don't know who's Shane what and
who's doing what
what I do know is that
um army hammers accused rape no good but
uh people have come out I believe the
authorities and said yeah it's kind of a
you just live to obey and be my slave
I will own you that's my soul my brain
my spirit my body now by the way it's
fun if you want to have a little fun you
know when a Postmates driver contacts
you and goes I'm seven minutes away send
this
it's fun send this
would you come and be my property till
you die again nothing offensive yet
unless you send it to a black lady
not good if he's doing that then that's
not good but if it's uh you know if I
wanted to cut off one of your toes and
keep it with me in my pocket
so I always had a piece of you in my
possession hot
oh my God that just made me so hard it
makes me confused as to why is that even
possible
so hard thinking of holding your heart
in my hand and controlling when it beats
that's hard to do
I am 100 accountable I want to eat you
[__] that's scary to admit I've never
admitted that before
I've cut the heart out of a living
animal before and eating it while
someone here's the thing
here's the thing I defended a lot of
this really before I read
the text I came out very Pro him in the
beginning I didn't do a ton of I don't
really research the show I don't do a
ton of prep work I never have in seven
years of talking I do everything as it
happens on screen I figure things out I
read during the week and I talk to
people during the week but like I don't
do deep dives into these issues before
they happen I I imagined that Mr Hammer
was kind of like it was kind of like ooh
I want to eat you I want to put you in a
smoothie but
I don't love this I've eaten uh live
animal's heart before do we believe him
do we think do we believe him or do we
think he's just trying to be cool
Hammer had carved the letter A
okay so this is interesting on January
25th a 22 year old Instagram influencer
named Paige Lorenz another woman Hammer
had dated after separating from his wife
told the New York posts page six that
hammer had carved out the letter A near
her vagina with a knife licked the wound
proposed quote consuming her and told
her that he wanted to eat one of her
ribs
I thought he was kidding Lorenz said
I it didn't register to me this was
something he was serious about until he
brought it up multiple times and seeing
other woman would come out and say the
same thing
and then it was like wow this is really
scary
um
she said the incision was about an inch
deep and engraved with the whole
tip of the blade and of course his
lawyer goes that's not
true
I mean
what if you want to eat people
to be honest like in our society
which is relatively permissive in many
uh Arenas and I think that's good
I think people should be allowed to live
as they want
but if you wanted to eat a person if
that was the or is there a way to do it
safely
where someone who has been who has died
could consent or maybe their family
could get money so that people like
Armie Hammer with money not the poor can
indulge in this but is there a way that
people like Armie Hammer with money can
pay their families off to eat their
corpses of their relatives
to be honest like that might be
is that a crazy idea
like if let's say your son or daughter
died in a I don't know a motorcycle
accident could someone like Armie Hammer
go to the family and say I will cover
the funeral expenses and give you 150 on
top but I want to eat them
I want to eat your daughter
I'm gonna need her body and I'm going to
we're going to consume her flesh and can
this be done safely
um
I'm just proposing things I think might
make sense
um and like
man when it rains it pours
he also committed other acts of violence
against me to which I did not consent
you and on for example he beat my feet
with a crop what so they would hurt with
every step I took for the next week but
do you understand how hot Armie Hammer
is get up a photo of him understand how
hot you have to be a better one than
that even though that's not bad he's got
the porn stash do you understand how
attractive you have to be to beat a
woman's feet and carve letters into her
without her caring
I mean he doesn't even look he doesn't
look phenomenal there what about to the
left right there that's maybe a little
better yeah I mean you it's a statement
to how attractive he is that he was able
to carve things into women and beat
their feet and then basically they're
like oh my God he's just so weird we
love him so now he's broken his silence
and I don't know if I'm going to support
him but I may I may throw the full
weight of this show behind Army Hammer
our full uh you know the the microphone
here the bully pulpit the platform are
we going to back Army Hammer even though
he does he has carved things into people
and claims that he has eaten a beating
animal heart
um the thing about it his statement that
he released
um by the way he attempted suicide after
this
so this whole idea of like
like that we're just gonna pile on
to this poor man
he said Hammer said in February he
attempted suicidal quarantining in the
Cayman Islands I just walked out into
the ocean and swam as far as I could and
hoped that either I drowned was hit by a
boat or was eaten by a shark then I
realized that my kids were still on
Shore and then I couldn't do that to my
kids
he lost between 14 and 16 million
dollars alone
as he was removed from multiple movie
projects
my financial status is not only am I
broke I'm massively in debt
there was a point in all this where I
had to have a friend to help me buy
groceries
but yet and this is my favorite lie I
love by the way there's nothing better
than this and this is what everyone says
after they've been through something
like this
he wouldn't change it
you wouldn't change it for the world
this is my favorite this is because it's
to show that they've learned this is
this is what you have to do you have to
actually show that you've learned this
guy was one of the let's just put this
in context he was one of the biggest
celebrities in the world he was a movie
star uh beloved by the industry of
Hollywood he was a multi-millionaire he
um
he then was outed as being a cannibal
and a rapist and sent to an island uh to
sell time shares
and he wouldn't change a thing
he wouldn't change a thing
um he says it made him a better person
and a father to his children made him a
better dad
being outed as a cannibal
has made him a better father he's around
now to throw the ball
with his kids if someone came up to me
and gave me a magic lamp and said
there's a Genie in here but it only
gives you One Wish by the way this is
the biggest lie that first of all if
there's a Genie in a lamp that gave him
one wish he wants a woman tied to a
[__] table in that Epstein little
Temple that they had on little Saint
James
this idea that I mean I love this stuff
listen to this quote I get it you can't
be on after you've been outed as
accountable
honesties would [__] you honesty
[__] him
he was too honest he went out and said I
want to eat women I can't believe I'm
admitting that I feel so close to you I
want to eat you I want to put your toe
in my pocket and carry it around that's
just me being me that's Army being Army
and then the honesty is what really
[__] him so he can never be honest
again a guy like Army Hammer is swimming
out in the Cayman Islands maybe maybe he
thinks he's gonna get eaten by a shark
maybe not but he can never be honest
again he knows that he knows down deep
honesty is the worst policy for him it
just didn't work it didn't work at all
he let everybody know what he was into
and then they responded by uh ruining
his life so he'll never be honest again
ever about anything because you by the
way those thoughts don't go away you
don't go away if you're at a restaurant
you see an attractive waitress and she
hands you a meal and you look at her
forearm and you go good I just want to
[__] bite into that I just want to
bite into this bitch's arm that doesn't
go away I don't think it goes away maybe
with some therapy but still it's a kink
it's just something you're into
he goes if somebody came up to me and
gave me a magic lamp and said there's a
Genie in here but it only gives you one
wish if you rub the slam the genie will
come out and take you back two years in
the past and you can undo all of this
which by the way sounds great
I wouldn't do it says Army Hammer he
would not do it I am now grateful for
everything by the way you have to
realize I don't know what publicist is
working with him probably no but like
this is probably this is probably the
lowest like he's kind of been written
off and it's kind of sad
um well I don't know what he actually
did I mean he's doing some things that
are not great clearly The Carving and
all that and the beating but uh this is
not like this is what he you know it's
still kind of arranged like this is a
comeback he wants a comeback this is
what it's for otherwise he just quietly
learn all these lessons
need to publicly tell people that he's a
great dad
um
who is this who are these people
hold on
hello
hi Aunt Carol how are you
thank you my love how are you doing
thank you for the birthday wishes
it's okay I forgive you
I know you're great how are you feeling
good
of course
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 more than 50 million men in
the U.S suffer from male pattern
baldness keeps us more than uh more than
five star reviews than any of its
competitors I love keeps everyone I know
uses it all the bald people I know have
hair now because they've kept the hair
on their head with keeps keeps his
personalized treatment plans that are
recommended by a licensed medical doctor
and delivered straight to your door with
keeps you can get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or Pharmacy easily subscribe to keeps
and get refill reminders so you'll never
run low on the products that you need to
take care of your hair they have 24 7
care and support keeps as a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime and these treatment
plans are affordable typically have the
cost of Pharmacy prices whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair that you have keep says you
covered remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
for results so fast so if you're ready
to take action to prevent hair loss go
to keps.com Tim Dillon to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
keps.com Dylan to get your first month
of treatment for free
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dillon to get
your first month of treatment for free
I'm now grateful for everything that's
happened to me because as it says in the
12 and 12
which is the Alcoholics Anonymous 12
steps to 12 traditions uh pain is the
Touchstone of spiritual progress Hammer
says I'm now healthier happier more
balanced cannibal I'm able to be there
for my kids in a way I never was I'm
able to be there for my dad as he's
dying in a way that I would never have
been able to be I'm truly grateful for
my life and my recovery and everything I
would not go back and undo everything
that's happened to me hey if it's true
God bless I would imagine uh that it is
not
because I think best case scenario you
would not have any of that happen and
then um recover from being accountable
privately if
possible but no one can prove he ate
anybody
um
so it's interesting
this this rape allegation that he's
going through and again this is in the
show where we're like investigating rape
claims here
um Luis Gomez there was there was I mean
who I loved you know Louis Gomez I
always say Louis Gomez his name is Louis
J Gomez but it's a way to disrespect him
but Lewis who's a great friend of mine
and the the proprietor of gas digital
Legions everything Lewis it was like
Open Mic there was an open mic rape
claim and the Lewis came to me goes we
and we started investigating it it was
very interesting we found all these
weird things was like a Weird True Crime
tang and then Lewis says we should do a
show called rape dicks where
investigators and we investigate rape
claim which we never did because the
advertisers I don't think would have
been in love with the idea but just rape
dicks was going to be
so this woman is accusing a hammer of
raping her for howering for hours the
stamina
but the actor says while he did have an
affair with the consensual 24 year old
everything was consensual or consensual
non-cut and by the way everyone's
[__] on Leo who's a non-accountable
for [__] a 19 year old he's not
dating a 19 year old
what I mean the guy listen he's Leo the
cap stop saying he doesn't respect women
he respects him especially when they're
young
I mean there's is that inherent that he
doesn't respect women he's dating United
generals he probably connected with her
on a deep level that people don't
understand
it's not you know
you know when you're Leo DiCaprio should
you date an old hag
and I'm not saying that like
you know I get it's a little bit of a
gap the 19 and whatever he is 60 or
something it's a gap it's a generational
Gap but the reality is should you date
it all would it make everyone feel
better to see Leonardo DiCaprio with the
twice divorced vice president from New
York City who shoves her big rib eye
steak feet into flats and gets off a
Subway and goes
and walks into an office and gosh get
the [__] and she just smells like garlic
and she's like and then she's drinking
wine and she has three kids and in all
different colleges and you know she's
screaming at them all the time and would
it make everyone feel better Leo to [__]
her like I I don't know what who do you
what would make everyone feel good he's
not listen Leo DiCaprio he's not on the
same Planet you are dummies I'm sorry to
let you know that he's not in the same I
think and I've heard he just brings
women in he [__] him with headphones on
he puts headphones in his ears and [__]
him and then just like goodbye and I
think they signed an NDA I think that's
what he does and I get it because it's
like you know like I you know like I
think after a while it probably gets a
little bit annoying being Leo DiCaprio
just like I just want to [__] these
women and put my headphones in and not
deal with it so apparently now he's
found a 19 year old that he cares about
and then he likes and he wants to date
everyone's mad at him who should he date
what type of woman should he date like a
50 year old
gal
would that make everybody better to see
feel better to see Leo with like a
graying old librarian
that comes out and he's like this is my
I love her her passion for books
that's what I love it's her passion for
books God she's opened my eyes to so
many things Leo he's going out
is this his girl yep
listen what's good about see what's
interesting about this 19 year old is
she looks 14. now Leo I mean listen he's
in love She's an Israeli model he's in
love with her do you hate love
do you people hate love
they probably talk about all kinds of
interesting things
she's probably like [__]
you know my father is in the military
and
the other day he you know they strapped
a bomb to a Palestinian toddler and then
he just kind of ran and he ran and then
he went on Leo goes hung Leo might have
for the whole relationship maybe he has
his headphones in he doesn't know what
she's saying but I don't judge people as
long as everything's legal and
consensual it's like
I don't know should he date an old hag I
know a lot of hags in my I know a lot of
old female hags and I love them I love
them I don't [__] them but I love them
they're a lot of fun they have great
personalities but Leo's maybe not into
that because Leo probably doesn't have a
personality either that's the other
thing people are like well what does he
even relate to the girl about what does
he relate to anyone about he's Leonardo
DiCaprio he's not cool like he is in the
movies he's just probably a dull guy
who's just ready really to go some to
some other planet because he's done this
one there's nothing left for him to do
back to Armie Hammer who I feel I'm
increasingly bad for uh now because he's
going insane this alleged rape was a
scene that was her idea she planned all
of the details out all the way down to
what Starbucks I would see her at how I
would follow her home how her front door
would be opened and unlocked and I would
come in and we would engage in what is
called quote consensual non-consent
scene a consensual non-consent by the
way anybody who's a famous actor doing
this
be careful
consensual non-consent scene Hammer says
every single thing was discussed
beforehand I have never thrust this on
someone unexpectedly that was very part
of the BDSM world he said the consent
because you're doing things that are
pushing envelopes you're doing things
that are beyond the realm of let's have
missionary sex with the lights off which
again Army is bored with you have to
have that trust you have to have that
vulnerability with somebody you have to
have that aspect of I'm willing to give
my control over to this person
and they're the ones that can stay stop
at any time they're the ones who can set
the boundaries and jealova maintains it
there is there is in the region of 100
plus people that Mr Hammer has coerced
in his sexual acts coercion's an odd
term but
um you know so here's the thing with
Army Hammer we wish well we apologize uh
but we have a Chinese spy balloon in
America so we can't devote too much time
to this we have a spy balloon I haven't
looked at this too much
um and uh but what this is uh is uh a
cartoon what a cartoonish this is like a
90s movie like an early 2000s movie that
it we're being spied on with a balloon
uh and Joe Biden's like we're gonna
we're gonna take care of this uh
surveillance balloon believed to be from
China and first scene above Montana is
being tracked as it flies over the
continental United States the government
has detecting it it's tracking its high
altitude surveillance balloon that is
flying over the continental United
States right now is this what try I
thought China was very sophisticated I
thought China was doing like a lot of
corporate Espionage and they had spies
in this country that are born here like
my godson that will grow up and live
here like I I thought China was doing
this really high level [__] this is what
they're doing they're setting a hot air
balloon maybe we don't really have to
worry about them this is what they're
doing they're sending a blimp
spy on people I don't know this doesn't
seem to I thought China was like I mean
really like like you know deeply
entrenched in our security state with
their spies and our defense industry and
many and tech and and corporations but
so Biden praise the Top Gun F-22 fighter
jet pilot who shot down China's spy
balloon off the coast of South Carolina
with a single missile
after the president vowed to take care
of it and the FAA closed airspace and
three airports so it's weird it's like
it's and then what does try I guess we
go to China and go you have a [__]
spy button to go oh I don't know they go
we don't really know we don't just uh
it's just a hot air balloon but this
does I'm not I'm am I is it okay to be
less worried about China now that this
is the type of crap they're doing like
frat pranks they're sending hot air
balloons to spy on Montana maybe they
don't really know what's going on we
tend to think China's like the biggest
threat but maybe they're not we don't
know I mean this this kind of makes me
feel a little better about them to be
honest the balloon which was being used
by the People's Republic of China and
now by the way here's what we're gonna
find out soon it's our Balloon by the
way this is what we're gonna fight this
comes next what comes next is that it is
an American Balloon that we have put up
to stoke some cold war with them now
because the Ukraine's that one's winding
down perhaps so what we're going to
realize is that we did this this sounds
like something we might have done this
sounds like an idea that comes out of
our defense department what if we put a
let's do a bob balloon you put it over
Montana yeah we say it's a Chinese
balloon we say it's a Chinese
surveillance balloon they'll believe
that oh yeah they'll believe that yeah
they'll believe that let's see can we
get a video of the Chinese spy balloon
yeah this this is and then someone shot
it yeah this is like 100 percent
this feels like it's 100 something we've
done so it's a Chinese uh we're gonna
see it's a spot it's a it's a spy
balloon it's a Chinese spy balloon
well Biden yeah I mean you know people
are saying he's not tough on these
things so you know the reality is We
Can't Ban Tick Tock you know but what we
can do is put up a fake uh spy balloon
and then shoot it down yeah oh yeah oh
they'll love it it'll dominate the news
cycle for two or three days which is put
up a balloon and then shoot it and then
yeah we act like it's a big win I don't
know maybe maybe it is China but I don't
know I'd be so disappointed in China if
this is the [__] they're doing the
Chinese spy balloon
I I just I just hope uh I hope that this
is not what the case is I do want to
talk about a nice story because there is
there's very few nice stories out there
now and I want to talk about something
that I do think is nice there is a
family there was a family a mother a
father and a daughter
this is actually nice truly so if you
want like
some dark angle on this there is none
it's a genuinely nice story where people
do what they say this was a family who
had a suicide pact and actually did it
like they actually followed through on
it and killed themselves the mom shot
the dad the daughter shot the mom and
then the daughter shot herself there's
something really nice about a family
that not only makes a plan but executing
did you guys find any of the YouTubes of
her yeah
so this lady this woman her and her
family
um all shot each other in a suicide pact
where were they from do we know
Pennsylvania they're from Pennsylvania
these people and they're they're big
Trump fans and probably on the Q
spectrum and the there was a note left
by the mother saying there was evil
mounting against the daughter I think
they believed that maybe the daughter
was
uh taken over by the spirits
and but there's a YouTube of the
daughter here and this is always creepy
to watch somebody uh from Beyond the
Grave a little bit but let's check out
this Twitter because the mother has said
there's evil being mounted against the
daughter let's see why she would think
that
this accident really
hello everyone
Morgan Elizabeth Pennsylvania
United States of America
oh
I think the Privacy being stolen but I
hope this rocks the world today
please do
the mother was correct the mother was
correct and the elimination was
necessary
um the mother was correct the
elimination had to happen uh whatever
this is we don't need that we don't need
more of that
we don't need more of whatever that is
if that's not evil I don't know what
evil is uh somebody from York
Pennsylvania talking British accent I
hope his travels the world what a great
look at this creepy [__]
she's a little creepy and she's got what
has she got the shirt on the American
Beautiful shirt
you buy these shirts at like rest stops
like that type of shirt
so now what happened Morgan didn't have
many words to say he said uh Brett
stably who operates the pro shop at the
bowler Supply so this girl was uh quiet
but apparently intelligent
um and he gave her many bowling lessons
over the years and she became more
sociable as she grew older but
these people
um they were hell-bent on Trump winning
I don't know why that
it's like a huge part of this apparently
that's but what do they do how do they
do it they shot each other I think
the mom shot the dad and the day they
had a pact and they had a note that said
our daughter has been uh possessed which
is true this is clearly true if you if
you watch the Youtube there is some
level of possession there to be honest
I'm not even trying to be
whatever but the girl was you know the
girl was under something under some
influence it was not
good
um
yeah so they found notes inside the
house that indicate the family recently
made a joint decision to end their lives
police believe Deborah daub shot and
killed her husband and then was shot and
killed by Morgan who then committed
suicide police said there were no signs
of forced entry and no evidence anyone
else had been present and investigated
but but here's the deal I mean this is I
got to be honest with you more families
should do this
because the real estate market is
tanking and this is a great way to
balance things out if families start
killing themselves in Mass if they just
start having suicide packs
and because you don't want one or two
people in the family to go you want
everybody to go
because it's a clean slate Clean Slate
mother's chilling handwritten note about
evil that is mounted against her
daughter who shot her parents dead
before turning the weapon on herself and
family murder suicide pact a cryptic
handwritten note was left by the mother
of a young Pennsylvania woman which
spoke of evil mounted against her
just days before they were found dead in
a planned murder suicide pact yeah
do we have the note
probably not it's probably still
evidence yeah
this is sad but again
you know play a little bit more in this
video huh about two minutes in it starts
getting good she like switches
personalities a little bit yeah I guess
let's play more of this video because I
do to be honest with you I do believe
she's being controlled by demons the
YouTube go to the YouTube and I believe
that at the end of the day if you can
you know
if you can just
kill each other
nicely and quietly
maybe that's not the worst
line for the throne of England
the kingdom
not anymore Donald Trump
not anymore Brock you're saying Obama
not anymore Wendy Rogers
it's done
oh I hope they're getting the papers
drawn up right now I want to shoot her
attorney's getting nice
those things set right now
please
as soon as possible
I mean imagine your child started acting
like this you'd have to kill them you'd
have to shoot them imagine if your child
started walking around the British
accent being like it was not your
kingdom anymore
good morning good morning it's another
Kings and many more Barack Hussein Obama
it's not a kingdom anymore you'd go all
right let's all kill ourselves
we don't know where we went wrong with
this [__] but we [__] up like I can
imagine the parents just hitting each
other looking at each other going listen
here's the reality uh we got a big
problem here we got a real big problem
here this is not turning around and we
did it we did this and it's not turning
around we gotta go we gotta take
ourselves out of the equation because
this is beyond a little time in therapy
this [__] is crazy we raised a [__]
lunatic and we gotta go play a little
more of this it's it's creepy it makes
my skin crawl be getting the official
paper
they get drawn up
faster than you can say queen really
will be
uh
you know I've never goes for too much
things he can help with the most high
God
this is what happens
I did so in a little bit of a paper here
a little bit of paper all right enough
it is there's about there's about 10 10
to 15 of the population is this if you
talk to them truly
about 10 to 15 of people you bump into
out there are uh in in the steps of uh
in Insanity truly where it's just it's
like doesn't even make sense it's like
non-secreative
she's speaking in a British accent
um you just yeah I I gotta be honest
with you I'm Pro I'm usually against
family suicide packs but uh this one I
completely support it was probably long
overdue I think that at the end of the
day the parents probably sat down to
dinner and went hey Ryan this ain't
turning around let's get this let's
eliminate this problem
oh is there dinner ready is the dinner
ready
no it's not a kingdom anymore isn't it
it's not a kingdom anymore
and they go we gotta kill her we gotta
kill her and then ourselves because we
don't want to go to jail everybody's
Gotta Die we'll get her to kill us and
we'll get her to take her on life
um
to defend my Irish people right now
they're coming after kerrygold butter
which is a great butter it's very yellow
and gamey it's from uh Ireland it's uh
made by white people
um which is nice because a lot of things
are not and it's made by Irish red white
people and of course uh the bay area
which has no respect for the Irish you
never will
um is uh the Irish don't have anything
this is the thing about the Irish they
have nothing they have like story and
song uh they don't have any real wealth
there's no Finance they just have
natural beauty but it's kind of
depressing and sad and this is what the
Irish and I love the Irish because this
is like what I am but you know at the
end of the day they're like the lowest
class of whites they're not the best
looking they have many skin problems
they're they're they drink a lot but
again they're very hardy people that
tell great stories and have some really
good music not I wouldn't call it
mainstream but you know there you know
so they're just trying to get by here
and the thing they're they're export
their big things butter it's carry gold
butter you know this is what they do you
know and uh Kerry golden all natural
butter the choose anything from baked
goods to breakfast omelets was yanked
from California New York grocery stores
recently Bay Area Costco employees told
San Francisco gate apparently it's
traditional foil packaging might not
comply with California's new law on
hazardous chemicals come on
will you come on now
these people live in tiny Huts in
Ireland and they churn [__] butter
they don't understand it it hazardous
chemical laws in California they're just
trying to make butter so that they can
[__] buy more cows to make more
butter they don't even they're not
making a lot of money on this they're
just trying to stay above water I speak
for my own people here they're trying to
stay above water over there and they're
just trying to [__] get enough butter
and to have more but this is It's a
butter economy in Ireland it's a
butter-based economy is there one export
it's the one thing they have oh would
you like some categorical butter that's
all they have there's nothing else they
don't have anything else they're not
expect they're not making
microchips they don't know what they
even are they don't know what those
things are
if Ireland has an Apple store I'm
shocked and if they have it they
firebombed it because they think that's
where the witches work
you know what I mean it's just a
beautiful sad place to have a nice cup
of tea and look at the rain on the
cliffs and think of throwing yourself
off a guy that I was hanging out with
from Ireland said this is true this is
just sums up Ireland and then you take
the [__] butter away it just sums it
up a guy married some chick
he was like suicidal and he went to the
Cliffs of Moher which are these
beautiful cliffs in Ireland and the
family's like trying to stop him they
all get there and they watch him throw
himself off
like the bride the whole family they're
all there and then this guy just throws
himself off and they're all like no and
they run towards the cliffs and they see
he's throwing himself again you want to
stop their ability to ship butter
to America
to the People by the way San Francisco
do you think the biggest problems in the
Bay Area is the Hazardous plastic butter
packaging okay there are people in the
Bay area right now who are are literally
full zombies walking around in a [__]
post-apocalyptic uh I Am Legend state of
being where they're just like making
sounds they don't even speak to him
[Music]
and we're worried about the packaging on
the butter products that are being
shipped here from the the Santa everyone
in Ireland was like raped by a priest
and they're all trying to get over that
by drinking copious amounts of booze
they drink fish tanks and booze every
day to get over the fact that all of
them are kind of raped by by uh did I
say police or priests priests yeah they
were raped that's America
Ireland Ireland they're raped by priests
and they all get over that by drinking a
lot so many of them are drunk most of
the day and ones that aren't make butter
this is like the only thing they've have
going on this is the whole country to be
honest
and if you know maybe there's a
restaurant where they're serving the
butter other than that this is It's the
whole economy there's no like huge
financial decision they're not like a
tech country nobody detect nobody tech
people moving to Ireland right so at
kerrygold we made the responsible
decision to reformulate some of our
packaging due to regulatory changes in
California which went into effect
January 1st 2023 product with peas free
packagings returning to shelves this
week onwards I'm just saying this hurt
the people you're hurting here are are
very sad troubled people do you know how
many of the people that carry gold are
committing suicide right now are
throwing themselves off a cliff because
the butter is not being shipped to the
San Francisco many of them are just good
they're all just a lot of them are just
walking to the Cliffs of mar and jumping
off
it's horrible it's very sad so I'm just
saying get the [__] get the butter
back on the [__] shelves please let
these people live
let Army Hammer live he made a few
mistakes he carved one heart into a
woman's [__] and we're acting like he's
irredeemable and can't come back he did
one wrong thing he said I want a cat I
want to eat your toe to one person and
it's a big deal
uh this is one of my favorite things are
always the Hugo Soto Martinez he was
like an LA guy he's like we don't want
any cops one of his staffers called the
LAPD asking for extra Patrol on Lexus uh
public points out hypocrisy
um I guess he has a Lexus Hugo Soto
Martinez and uh
I I don't know he wanted to abolish the
police but
he has a Lexus and he wants the cops to
Patrol his Lexus I guess that's what I'm
getting from this but this is all of
them right this is like
um all of the people that really push
aggressively to like abolish the cops
like a lot of them are in a position
where they
have to eventually call the police and
embarrass themselves
you know
LAPD received a call from Mr Soto
Martinez's office asking for quote extra
patrols throughout the night because a
parked white Lexus belonging to the
council member uh because the vehicle
broke down
so he didn't want people stealing his
car I guess
um
yeah I mean this is you know this is
this is silly uh they tell they tell
people that they don't want any cops
and
you know then they're like hey can you
guys can you guys
just watch my Lexus
also everything in La is falling apart
rapidly the cops have probably have a
lot of [__] to do and so they just have
to kind of go around and
just do a drive and look at his Lexus
but yeah I mean people like when people
lie people really actually like this so
this is not uh a bad thing none of this
ever Matters by the way no no no no
hypocrisy is a charge doesn't really
work
no one cares most people are hypocrites
so most people treat Hypocrites well
they don't really care
um you know when someone who pushes
defund the police then it turns out they
want a private Patrol by their house
they don't really care when people who
uh say that their anti-gon have uh
guards with guns all around they don't
care when people who are pro-immigration
live behind three or four guard Gates
they don't care this hypocrisy charge
doesn't really work because in America
the goal is to be a hypocrite that's the
whole goal is to really be a hypocrite
like being successful means you'll have
to kind of on some level be a hypocrite
because a lot of the things you're going
to push or say are bad for people you're
gonna do
and this is the goal and people know
that like instinctively I think people
know that like they're just like if I
could get be successful enough to be a
hypocrite that's the goal the goal is to
basically go out and say this is the way
things should be but not for me because
as soon as you have money you can buy
your way out of the conditions you're
even talking about right as soon as you
have a little bit of money
you buy your way out of these conditions
you buy your way out of the crime
neighborhood you buy your way out uh you
get a bunch of lawyers uh so that people
can't [__] with you the way they used to
uh you're not uh being taken advantage
of by greedy landlords at that uh to
that to to that you know extent that you
were that sole goal is to be Hypocrites
nobody really cares it's hypocrisy it's
like in Hollywood where I live
everybody's like
that's the whole point the whole point
is to be a hypocrite you know you you
care about climate change but they're on
the private jet but I mean I don't know
what's the other side the other side of
it should not take the private chat then
Leo's and coach was his 19 year old
girlfriend Leo's sitting there on Coach
I mean that would be ridiculous I'm not
a coach in first class but that would
also be kind of ridiculous like Leo
being in first class would be ridiculous
right so he's got to take a private jet
he's just hostile he's gonna do it what
he should do is just stay quiet about
the environment that would be nice if
you just didn't really care about it but
because he you know because he can't go
the other way right he can't be like
[__] the environment like you can't be
excited about destroying the environment
that would seem uh in bad taste that
would be in poor taste if Leo was like I
don't give a [__] about this planet I'm
almost done here and when I'm done here
I hope the whole thing blow like that
would be in bad so he's got to get out
and kind of go like yeah it's just to be
you know the oceans are beautiful and
you know grass we like grass and
mountains we like that and air clean air
is good and so he's real but that's
that's why hypocrite never works you can
hit people with any type of charge and
it'll work racist homophobic uh whatever
it is those things work people like that
hypocrite people go no no no no no no no
that doesn't matter
what people say in this country is
inherently more important than what they
do truly like when those gay politicians
that have wives and kids they secretly
get caught sucking off dudes in the
airport like yeah a lot of them lose
their jobs and stuff like that but it
doesn't make people think differently
they still go no no well we we still are
against gay marriage we're gonna elect
another guy like the message never gets
hurt the message will never get hurt by
the hypocrisy we like hypocrite we like
liars it's a big thing and our Dream As
Americans is to one day be Hypocrites
that's our Dream It's like if everything
goes right in your life in this country
you could be a hypocrite and you can go
the [__] it's so sad but with the
climate it's sad but then everything you
do will be to get away from people all
the stuff that would help the climate is
like Public public [__] more public
transportation more this more that but
you don't want to be on any of that
they're kind people's handsaw you don't
want to be on it so the reality is you
you immediately will then go no no I
want to be in my own [__] car I want
to be away from these [__] people if
I go on vacation I don't want to go
anywhere near the people they get away
from the people so the whole thing is is
is like just
just who cares
doesn't matter it doesn't really matter
uh that this guy goes get rid of the
police and then he wants police it's
like that's our our most American ideal
is that we we say one thing and do
another that's everything we've ever
that's the whole point that's that's as
deeply ingrained in America is every day
we are for freedom and democracy and we
like the Middle East on fire for 20
years it has nothing to do with anything
we're sticking it out until we win and
we're out of Afghanistan we run away
like cowards you're killing people it's
all a lie the whole thing's a lie so why
would these people be honest the whole
thing's a lie the whole thing's
completely alive so it's just nice
because there's there sometimes the rest
stop has to a seat available at the
restaurant that's what most people like
about America it's like air conditioning
uh fluffy couches
food you don't really care about much
House theme parks big movie plexes malls
like most people if you ask what they
like about America beer drugs boats
being on a boat when you're on drug like
they don't really care about anything so
like hypocrisy doesn't matter these
people well he's being hypocritical what
they go what does that even mean it's it
it's it's our national religion to be
Hypocrites it's our national religion to
go into a country kill them all and then
and and then ask why they don't like us
that's what we do as a car we like kill
a whole country and they go what's their
problem with us it's like so yeah of
course none of this [__] matters but
they'll keep doing this they'll keep
they'll keep bringing this [__] up like
it's ever gonna matter like anyone's
ever gonna care about hypocrisy it's
just it's a national Pastime it's a
national religion to say one thing and
do the other and to to just believe
[__] believe nonsense every story of
all these successful people they come
out and it's designed by like publicists
and writers for a lot of it and it's you
know
literally you know the whole thing about
I don't freak out about the nepo baby
thing but there are so many people in
the entertainment business whose parents
were successful I don't think that's
necessarily bad by the way it's just a
thing right it's just what it is and
it's it it's just what it is you know
it's not uh it doesn't invalidate their
talent because some of those talented
people have genes and they get passed
down to people that are good you know
it's like you know like I am the sun
bring this guy up I am the son this is
true of Bobby The Brain Heenan
so I that's how I
have been able to do what I've been able
to do in this business and it's you know
it doesn't invalidate my talent it
doesn't invalidate everything I've done
it doesn't invalidate all of the things
that I do every week for all of you
people but you know that's
um
all right everybody thank you for
listening we'll see you next time